avoir un peu de lumière sur le magasin juste pour montrer
aux gens que c'est le quartier algérien
dans la ville de Qamishli
[Musique] [
Musique] [Musique] [
Musique] [
Musique]
immigrer
[Musique]
ici il y a une frontière turque et voici
les mots principaux  et sarakin est
là-bas vous pouvez voir la ligne des plans
dans le ciel la situation est vraiment mauvaise
ici beaucoup de gens ne sont pas immigrés
de la région immigrer à la sauce
combat il y a beaucoup de frappes sur des
points militaires dans des endroits où nous  entendu également
dans un ISA, ils ont bombardé un endroit dans le
ciel, nous pouvons voir la classe turque maintenant
les gens immigrent à la sauce
à cause des frappes turques des milliers
de personnes des milliers de personnes
immigrent du côté doux les Turcs
ont dissuadé l'armée turque de bombarder
par  des mortiers partout
maintenant en deuxième année à la place de la campagne d'Akane
[Musique]
maintenant je suis dans le quartier d'al-charia Je suis
dans un quartier joyeux qui est un
quartier chrétien qui est mon
quartier et maintenant ils ont bombardé une
maison chrétienne la femme a été tuée et
l'homme  avec ses enfants, ils se sont blessés
juste pour voir que la route est fermée à cause des
instructions cette voiture ne peut pas traverser la
route ouais ouais les gens commencent juste à
utiliser les sous-sols et on peut voir qu'il
y a encore des familles ici ils ne veulent pas
quitter leur ville  ils ils grandissent
ici et ils veulent mourir ici
c'est quelqu'un qui a de l'eau maintenant nous sommes proches de
la frontière turque ici c'est un quartier tunisien c'est
une femme c'est une dame qui tient
les photos de leur fils il y a eu une
guérison et une fin de vie  dans la
guerre contre Isis et contre le tourisme
pour vaincre le tourisme ici et rendre
le monde plus sûr et maintenant ils
voient que les États-Unis et les
pays européens et la
communauté internationale nous ont laissé sous cette taxe
ici en Syrie du Nord
vous